[Music]
[Applause]
jason garrett former
head coach of the cowboys now working
for football night in america he is
working tonight jags and the raiders the
hall of fame game coverage begins a
special edition of football night in
america at 7 eastern on nbc and peacock
and uh jason kind enough to join us
give me the level of nerves of going
into a broadcast as opposed to going
into a game as a head coach in the nfl
hey dan it's great to be with you you're
a legend you know that right thank you
jace
uh you know i would say the biggest
thing for me is it's i haven't done it
before you know i played football for a
long time i coached football for a long
time you get into new experiences in
different environments in football but
you have something to kind of fall back
on a lot of experience this is new i
ended up doing eight usfl games in the
spring for nbc and i really enjoyed that
experience and i felt like every week i
got more and more comfortable i worked
with jack collinsworth he was incredible
and and i learned a lot through that
experience so this will be new this will
be different but i'm excited about the
opportunity
and i look at both of these teams a year
ago john gruden is there a year ago
urban meyer is there
if you're going to handicap these two
teams because a lot of people love the
raiders this year feels like they're the
darlings in the afc west with who they
brought in so let's start there how
promising do the raiders look in your
opinion
well i think you can't forget about the
raiders they won 10 games last year and
one of the best coaching jobs done in
the nfl last year was by rich versace he
did an outstanding job as interim head
coach out there with all the things that
were going on in that organization to
keep everybody together they won four
games down the stretch they lost a close
playoff game in cincinnati and there are
a lot of really good pieces there
obviously josh mcdaniels comes in now
his second opportunity as a head coach
well documented that he feels like he
learned from the first experience and
he's going to go about it maybe a
different way this time but he has to be
excited about the pieces he has in place
how they played on offense the guys they
have they had devante adams so i think
there's a lot of stuff to be excited
about there with his second opportunity
in regards to jacksonville i think more
than anything else they just need to
right the ship uh they haven't been good
for a long long time and uh a lot of
single digit win seasons a lot of two
four six win seasons over the last few
years uh last year was a real challenge
for everybody so now doug peterson gets
his second chance and he obviously has a
winning pedigree won a super bowl in
philadelphia he's going to go try to put
his program in place down there and
maybe more than anything else
culture's an overused word but he's got
to get the culture right and he's got to
bring the right people in that's where
culture starts he understands how to do
that he started that process and they
just have to be patient there they can't
take any shortcuts they have a marquee
quarterback potentially great player and
trevor lawrence they got to create a
good environment for him so i see these
two teams being at different fate
different stages in their development a
10-win team a playoff team last year
with a new regime and then a team that
hasn't been good for a long time
so they'll approach it a little bit
differently i think i was wondering your
take obviously with what the browns are
dealing with with deshaun watson you
dealt with some high-profile cases greg
hardy zeke elliott when you were with
the cowboys what is the role of the
coach in a situation like that where you
don't know when you get them or what the
punishment's going to be
i think the biggest thing you try to do
as a head coach in 2022
uh
and probably really any time is is try
to keep your team focused on the things
they can't control again sounds like a
cliche sounds like coach speak but it's
so true there's so much distraction in
the world and when you have those
situations on your team sometimes your
guys can get distracted they can kind of
take their eye off the ball of what they
need to do each day to be a great player
and to have a great team so you're
constantly trying to reinforce that
message these are the things we can
control we can't control those other
things don't worry about those things
next man up mentality again another
cliche but it's real uh some of these
situations provide opportunity for
someone to step in and get a chance to
play you have to encourage those guys to
take advantage of those opportunities so
it's more about hey let's not get
distracted by this let's focus on what
we need to do to be our best
how would you describe the pressure of
being the cowboys head coach
obviously it's it's a marquee position
there's no question about that you know
everyone's talks about the yankee
shortstop the cowboy quarterback the
cowboy coach is the same kind of a
position
everything is highly scrutinized uh when
you have success maybe you didn't win
enough when you have some adversity you
know there's just a lot of attention
that comes with it
but but i never worked a day in my life
in dallas i absolutely loved it i
embraced every minute of it when we had
success certainly that was fun we had
some adversity hey you're trying to
build something you're trying to build
something great with the people you love
and care about so
that's kind of how i viewed it and uh
and i embraced it some of those things
as they say they come with the dinner uh
but but again uh you embrace those
opportunities it was a fun experience
okay now you got to get rid of that
description you can't use that in your
playbook here because the media is going
to take what you just said hey i never
worked a day when i was with the cowboys
they're going to take that then they're
going to twist it and be like garrett
didn't put in enough time as the cowboys
head co just just saying this is how
these things work they're going to pull
that quote chase yeah well i trust your
journalistic integrity oh it's not me
you don't have to worry about me you
know it's these other guys in the media
do you do a jerry jones impersonation
i don't but you know just
come on you do it jerry jones he can't
fire you now yeah
uh and then we'll get back to the jerry
jones impersonation yeah just to put a
button on it you know when you're in
those situations you know we used to
talk to our players about this all the
time ever since we were this high we
wanted a playing coach in the nfl and
you had these opportunities to do that
don't get distracted by all the other
stuff focus on what you love to do
and and when you know if you do what you
love and and you love what you do you
never work a day in your life and that's
something i really believe in and that's
something i was fortunate enough to do
in dallas for a long time you have one
super bowl ring
or two three i have three as a player oh
three
when do you bring them out
oh i don't bring them out i i rarely do
i was a bit player on some great teams
and
and uh again those were amazing
experiences to be a part of okay but
they're still yours i mean there are
yeah
but but so you don't wear them out you
would never do this like first night
football night in america
you know rodney rodney and tony they
sometimes bring out their hardware yeah
i was around some amazing players in
dallas for years and they always had an
incredible ability to go into a
restaurant and they'd do this
hey you know i was looking for a table
i was thinking about getting an upgrade
to first class
i maintain though jason that the nfl
should come out with a ring that's
really gaudy but then a ring that you
can wear out
it's it's like your wife with an
engagement ring or something that's a
little bit simpler nicer that you can
wear out and not feel like
like a class ring you know in the old
days what do you think yeah i i think
that's a pretty good idea you know when
we got those in the 90s we thought they
were the biggest things ever the 92
super bowl ring was incredible then hey
you know the next year it was so much
bigger 95 bigger than that i mean those
are like pinky rings compared to the
rings these days so uh i think your
point's well made
what is it like though when you're on
the sidelines when you're watching troy
aikman so being a quarterback but
watching him in the biggest game
games of his career
because i've stood on the sidelines and
i've watched these guys perform but i
didn't play the position and it's such a
different game when you're on the
sidelines watching this in real real
speed and you hear everything and those
hits are louder and all of that but
when you're watching troy
what's that feeling like on the
sidelines well i did play the position
and the position was always very hard
for me to play
and when i watched troy play he just
made the whole thing look so easy
and uh he had such great physical
ability
uh but he also had these amazing
instincts and this mental and physical
toughness and all these intangibles that
were just
so rare
and uh and he was always so prepared he
just seemed to handle every situation so
well so uh i always had great admiration
for him we played together for eight
years and he's a dear friend of mine so
i was always pulling like hell for him
i'll give you a quick story uh
he retires in 2000
i go to new york and play for four more
years as a backup
so it's the early 2000s and i'm actually
visiting him out in santa barbara
california before training camp he's a
broadcaster i'm a quarterback in the nfl
and we go work out together he's
probably you know he's in his mid-30s
and so we go lyft and we go run and
we're going to throw and so i've been in
off-season program i'm in shape i'm
doing the whole thing he hasn't thrown a
ball in a year and a half and so he's
catching for me and i'm dropping back
and it's all i can do to get the ball to
him and the whole deal and he's taking
the ball throwing it back to me like
it's nothing i'm like
i think the role should be reversed here
how do you explain brady at 45
i can't explain him i i can't begin to
explain him uh the year that he had last
year what he's done the last couple of
years
it's it's it's mind-boggling physically
he looks as good now as he did 20 years
ago
he moves as well he probably throws it
way better
obviously his understanding is off the
charts but 45 years old
the guys coming out are 20 and 21 and
they're quick and fast and explosive and
he continues to do this it's impossible
to understand i think we all need to get
on that avocado diet because uh
it's uh it's something else and you know
i've said this i've said this publicly
he's the greatest football player that
ever played and it's hard to even begin
to make an argument about anybody else
just his production over time and what
he's done
you know he was in new england and they
were a championship team
tampa bay won seven games the year
before he goes to tampa they win the
super bowl new england wins seven games
so it's like you know his impact
obviously is significant he's made a lot
of players around him uh have a lot of
success through the years and certainly
a lot of coaches as well he's just he's
an amazing football player but explain
to me what you see that's different than
what other quarterbacks see you went to
princeton like you know so your your iq
is not question but football iq
this is
this is different what brady's doing but
i'm trying to understand when you're out
there can you teach what brady is doing
well obviously the experience helps him
he's been in every situation imaginable
he's seen every front he's seen every
blitz he's seen every coverage over and
over and over again and practice in
games in every situation so he's a smart
guy he cares a hell of a lot about
football so he studies it he remembers
the experiences he learns from the
experiences he loves the game no stone
is unturned
and then i do believe as my dad used to
say
when you come out and the doctor wax in
the behind some some guys
have some of that stuff in them so he
has some instincts that are that are
born and then he's incredibly well
prepared and he loves it and uh he just
processed the game processes the game so
quickly if you watch him play he knows
exactly where he wants to go with the
ball before it hits his hand
boom boom boom it's out boom boom boom
it's out boom boom boom it's out and he
does that over and over and over again
and uh
he's just he's a rare human being
there's no doubt about that
give me a complicated play you had in
dallas so you you send the uh the play
in
and then i'm i'm gonna get it from you
how about you give me two because did
you would you normally send in two plays
and then depending on what was happening
at the line of scrimmage yeah a lot of
different versions of that you have
these things called kills or check with
me yes sir all right so send something
in to me
uh how about explode to gun bunch right
motor scat right triple seam burst kill
32 post
how many options do i have off that one
play
well one's a pass play it's a shift
and then a motion and then it's a pass
play
and then if you don't like the look you
say kill kill kill we're gonna kill it
to a rotting play
so that's kind of a basic
run pass kill type thing this is kind of
predates the rpos okay give me a sip
give me the simplest play call ever
that you would call
emmitt smith is the leading rusher in
nfl history his favorite play was i
write lead draw right
and he's the eye
well he's he dots the eyes we're gonna
run lead draw daryl johnston leads up on
the mike linebacker we block the guys
over so we hand it to emmett he finds
the holes and
he probably ran that play for about 10
000 yards
that's one of those that you knew it was
coming you could tell the defense it was
coming and you got larry allen it didn't
matter right
yeah well larry and a lot of other guys
and then when you have michael irvin
outside and alvin harper and jane
overcheck and aikman's your quarterback
there's a lot of weapons do you got a
michael irvin story for us that's okay
for this show
i do i do okay um
michael irvin is one of my favorite
people ever and uh troy aikman threw a
lot of balls to michael irvin in the
game that's why they're both in the hall
of fame i threw a lot of balls to
michael irvin on the side in practice
and and workouts leading up to practice
and uh
so it was it was july
and uh the time leading up to training
camp and this was the days of voicemail
and i was away and i get back
on a sunday
uh probably four days before we go to
camp
and i literally have 10 messages on my
machine from michael irvin saying red as
soon as you get back into town meet me
up at valley ranch as soon as you get
back in it doesn't matter what time
so it's it's literally like seven
o'clock at night on a sunday night and
just call it july 12th
and uh and so i go up there
and uh we used to do these things called
metabolics
10 routes
you run 10 straight routes you jog back
between the routes you take a 2 minute
break you go to the other side you run
10 routes and leading up to training
camp you would work your way up to five
sets of metabolics 50 rounds
so 50 throws for me 50 rounds for him so
i get up to valley ranch the practice
field it's still literally 100 degrees
out and michael irvin's waiting there
for me he's got his shoulder pads on
he's got a weighted vest on he's got a
weighted girdle
he's got his helmet on and that old
walter payton mouthpiece that he used to
wear
he's already warmed up he's ready to go
he's like red you ready
and so we had thrown enough balls
through the years that we really didn't
even have to talk to each other we knew
what was next and so i dropped back boom
i dropped boom boom boom there's his 10
routes you suck down two gatorades go to
the other side do it again and all the
while he's running the routes full speed
he's jogging back he's trying to get
ready to be great
and so he does this one set two sets
three sets i'm throwing i'm dropping
back it's not that hard for me he's
running the routes finishing the routes
doing the whole deal
fourth set fifth set we finish up he's
running nine rounded goal route down the
field and he's jogging back and i just
shook my head
it's 100 degrees it's 7 30 on a sunday
night on july 12th i said if you want to
be great you want to be a hall of famer
this is what you got to do as i see this
guy come back in his shoulder pads his
helmet his mouthpiece his weighted vest
his weighted girdle like wow
this is what it takes and for all of
michael irvin's craziness yes his
teammates saw this every day and that's
why he was so well respected the best
teammate any of us ever had
i was hoping for a different kind of
michael irvin story but that's okay i'll
give you the greatest michael irvin line
he was getting into trouble a little bit
once and
uh
i don't want to get into specifics of
what it was but he once
once told jerry jones boss man i was
just trying to do the wrong thing the
right way
that's also his greatness
oh i'm just trying to do the wrong thing
the right way
oh that's good hey have fun good luck
this year yeah thanks so much great
seeing you thank you bud that's uh jason
garrett